hey guys I got a lot of information for
you and a few announcements that I know
you're going to be very excited about
but first I just wanted to say thank you
and I don't say that enough or I do say
it enough and it's kind of lost its
meaning
I wrote a tumblr blog about this but you
guys didn't have to read that I'm
basically saying that in the two years
that I've been doing this I've said
thank you so much
and it's never lost its meaning for me
and I don't ever want it to lose its
meaning for you I don't ever want you to
think that I'm just saying thank you
just because I want you guys to expect
it or I think you guys want that from me
I'm saying it because I really and truly
mean it like especially with all the new
stuff that I've been trying to do for my
channel like the amount of work that I
put into editing each and every video
has gone up tremendously since just a
few months ago like a six seven minute
video which may seem short to you can
take like 50 minutes recording now and
then another two three hours of editing
it afterwards you know I'm trying so
many cool different things and some of
them may not seem cool to you because
you know I experiment with this one
comedy cut that a lot of people didn't
like and then this one that a lot of
people really did like but overall the
response has been absolutely amazing
like absolutely incredible and I'm so
grateful that you guys are willing to
join me as I try to expand and improve
on my videos especially with the
impossible let's play stuff now I know a
lot of people are not a lot but some
people were like oh no you're hurting
your self reviews we don't want this I
would never do anything that actually
puts me in harm's way
well not permanent harm's way anyway but
there's nothing wrong with doing a
little challenge for a laugh and I would
never go to the extreme lengths as some
people we're telling me to do but I
always want to try to mix it up and do
different things because I can't myself
I can't just repeat the same thing over
and over I can't just like record a
video slap it up and then throw it up on
my channel and expect you know I'm just
gonna rake in the views know what I want
is I want to explore like what I can
really do and how far I can really push
myself in terms of video making and I'm
just starting out even though I've been
doing it two years I'm just starting it
out
but I am so grateful that you guys have
given me the opportunity to do this and
you've given me the resources necessary
to explore these different things that I
can do and collaborate with these
amazing people that I am so honored to
work with and you know it just means a
lot to me that you guys are there for me
every day
and I don't say that enough because the
last time we did a vlog was three weeks
ago when we hit 2 million subscribers
and now we're already at 2.2 million and
that is just amazing so thank you guys
so much for everything that you've done
for me truly thank you alright on to the
important information you guys know I've
been doing a lot of collabs since I got
here well there's gonna be even more in
the near future I'm so honored because a
lot of these big youtubers that I've
been following for a while suddenly want
to work with me and I'm so honored that
they do and once a grant its credit to
you guys for pushing me to that point so
expect a lot more really cool collapse
in the future and a lot of really
interesting videos that I've been a part
of like the inácio punch thing with the
binge TV watching that was amazingly fun
but there's even more coming in the near
future and most importantly May 6
through the 11th my buddy Wade his
girlfriend Molly Bob my buddies from sin
ago Daniel and Brian are all coming to
LA to visit me for a five-day stretch
where we're just gonna go insane on
making videos more skate 3 with Bob and
a lot of games that you guys have been
demanding me playing but I have been
intentionally saving them for this point
where we can just go through a
smorgasbord of recording it's gonna be
five days of non-stop stuff it's gonna
be so much fun
I've been planning this forever now I
wanted to do a live stream while they
were here but I'm not set up for that I
literally have not had a time if you
look around anywhere off camera it is
still a mess there's still trash in
boxes I'm not set up to do a live stream
sadly but what we are going to do is
just going to make so many amazing
videos including sketch comedy videos
gameplay videos montages highlights
compilations funny stuff everything you
could possibly think of
I'm going to squeeze every little ounce
of hilarity we can out of that short
time that we have together so and and
also just to be honest it'll be really
good to see my friends again because it
has been a long time since I've been
able to hang out with him I've been
chatting with him online texting him but
um you know I came out to LA and I've
been working non-stop
every single moment of my life has been
you know all about working and I I
really can't wait to just have some of
my best friends in the world visit me
and us just get to hang out again
because God you know that's something
that I miss doing being out here but the
opportunities I get in LA are so great
and I can never forget that and I can't
forget that I'm doing all of this you
know for you guys you know I are really
really really am grateful for these
opportunities I've mentioned him before
I played a few games with them but I do
have a brother that does a webcomic
called two kinds now my brother has been
one of my biggest inspirations for
pushing me to do something on my own and
you know I don't give enough credit to
him or promotion for his own website so
you can find a link to his web comic
down in the description if you don't
know about it and he is just a really
cool guy and he's one of the people that
I missed the most being out here in LA
it's just really hard because me and him
were so close growing up you know we
never fought you know he's always been
my very best friend and you know if I
ever get married when that's gonna be
but you know he's always gonna be my
best man so you know I owe him a lot and
I owe a lot of people a lot of things so
but anyway I got I got sidetracked there
my brother is a really cool guy and I
owe him a lot that's all I'm trying to
say but he runs a webcomic that's
published through this company called
red giant entertainment now Red John I
mentioned before because they were the
ones who were really cool to both me and
my brother they're the ones who got him
his own booth at comic-con San Diego
comic-con by the way which I'm going to
be at this July and not only did they
give him his own booth and feature him a
lot
they gave me an exhibitor badge which is
something that the public can't get and
this was before I had you know any sort
of the success I had now I think I had
2,000 subscribers when I got there and
they still gave me an exhibitor badge
and they treated me like I was you know
royalty they treated me SuperDuper well
and they were really cool to me they're
just really cool
all company and so they asked me to help
them out because this Saturday is Free
Comic Book Day so they're launching this
line of free comics and if you don't
know what Free Comic Book days you can
look up I think it's Free Comic Book Day
com there's a link in the description I
don't know the website but you can go
there you find your local comic book
shop and if you go there you can get a
whole bunch of free comics so they asked
me to promote these and I don't usually
do promotions or trying to sell you guys
things but this company has been really
good to me and these aren't exactly
selling you anything because there is no
catch you just walk in and you ask for
the comics and they give it to you for
free so here they are they're launching
eight different titles across four comic
books so you can see they got this one
called first daughter Tesla which I read
and is actually really cool dual
identity Darkon and then you flip the
side over they got shadow children
indoors blog wayward sons which is
another really cool one and Magica which
is like a children's one but it's really
really well drawn like I love the yarn
though and that's absolutely fantastic
anyway they're all free they're all
totally free but I'm still trying to
sell you something so I feel dirty and
disgusting about it so I'm going to slap
myself in the face a wee again okay so
anyway that was just something I had to
do because I really don't like to run
promotions for you guys but these guys
has just been so cool to me so this
Saturday check it out the website to
find your comic book shop you can get
these all for free and the cool things
about these is these are the start of a
different line so they'll always be free
these actually aren't just free for free
comic book day these will always be free
you know they're just running the thing
they're ad-supported I think kind of
like YouTube you get free entertainment
but you have to watch an ad but it's
just like there's only like two ads in
there so it's pretty cool either way
haha
oh speaking of slapping myself in the
face I've got another impossible let's
play coming up very soon and it's got a
very special guest and it doesn't
involve physical pain maybe I don't know
we'll find out
can't wait all right so that's all I'm
gonna blab about for now I think I have
a red spot on my face so just thank you
guys so much for always supporting my
videos like just lately they've gotten
the biggest response I've ever seen I
think the hot sauce impossible let's
play is almost at a hundred thousand
likes and the closest I've gotten to
that is like fifty thousand like it's
unbelievable how much you guys have
supported me especially through these
really cool new things that I'm trying
so thank you guys so much I cannot wait
for my friends to get here and we can
all hang out and make the coolest videos
for you guys so thanks again for
everything that you've done for me and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
I